yeah yeah I'm open to whatever here's a
lady right here that has an issue gang
[ __ ] hi guys my name is Kelly and I'm a
9th grade English teacher in Las Vegas
in Marvis my school transitioned into
online distance learning which means I
didn't get a chance to prank my
archnemesis the 9th grade history
teacher open you guys can help me out
with that today while also uplifting my
students spirits Brendan I need you to
take it easy on the f-bombs here we go
told Aristotle once said that poetry is
finer and more philosophical than
history for poetry expresses the
universal history only the particular
here's the debate English teachers
versus history teachers choose wisely
dang game buzz buzz buzz Gaylords worked
a bomb-ass head Brendan yeah my bad
sorry I won't [ __ ] this up what I would
do well dude first of all English
teachers all day history teachers
talking that [ __ ] man just friend
them lies dude how about how about you
juice on some real facts like how about
George Washington wooden teeth I say
this
you mean teeth from the slaves those
teeth weren't wood and you think cut
down no [ __ ] apple tree well it's all
a bunch of lies man you think he soda
slaves tooth in his mouth that's more
realistic than sewing wood into his
[ __ ] mouth though it doesn't make
think about it easier to do something
right now
yeah what I'm saying is dude you could
easily put a piece of wood your mouth
looking a toothpick you're like gonna
stay there huh it's like you miss a
shape it you believe that [ __ ] the wood
would get soggy huh no put someone
else's tooth in your mouth bro that's
more realistic than wood look at this I
don't I don't know if I'm the only one
who has the the weird recollection of
being taught that George Washington had
wooden teeth anyway no his dentures were
made of teeth from his slaves yep from a
tote milk 40 okay 40 over budget mrs.
fields Bravo
you're gonna believe 40 and what was my
history teacher spending that [ __ ]
over Mariam and Webster dog from a real
history book
those books are fake oh my god a George
Washington and slave teeth according
George Washington's ledger
on May 8 1740 page six panelists who
shillings to Negroes for 90 on account
of dr. Lemoine so he was a middle man
dude so he was running teeth do you run
an enamel you had a hole teeth [ __ ]
skiing Doug said oh yes did you know
this that a lot of speaking of grills um
slave owners would get if they like
their slaves they would get gold put
into their mouths into the slaves Mouse
to show off their wealth Oh dance if I
can look I came from look I'm a dog
little Terry right here and Terry what
flex that gold yeah seven crazy damn
damn little Lance got one go Lance your
step his goddamn game up yeah yeah
Tyrone got all gold fronts but Lance was
also black I think it is gonna be a
black name yeah yeah Lance now is you
didn't have a black last 20 years ago
nope what do you don't think so you
think pinky had a homeboy Lance Oh Lance
the lyric was just my home book kickin
it with my homeboy Lance who said that
biggie
oh wow hmm what would the fans say uh
sixty sixty percent said history
teachers history is more fun for sure
you just said no no it was funner but I
like English teachers I like history cuz
they're pictures of cannons in the book
what it's more fun
[Laughter]
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]